Hello, Dr. Kevin Connors here again for your members minute trying to give minutes of
information to our members so that the more informed patients that we have better off
you're going to do.
So we've been talking about Lyme disease for the last several member minutes that we've
been talking about.
Lyme disease is a TH1 dominant disorder and that you can't take TH1 stimulants.
So TH1 is the killer side of your immune system.
So protocols that use things that are going to stimulate this side stimulate tissue destruction.
They may help for a period of time, but the patient ends up crashing.
It just doesn't work because you're destroying your own tissue.
So how do you kill biotoxin, a living organism, well that is a pathogen that is hurting you
and is injuring you and is out of balance like Lyme disease and all its co-infections.
How do you kill it if you can't stimulate the immune response?
Yeah, kind of tricky.
So we can't stimulate a TH1 response to kill Lyme disease.
That's where long-term antibiotics can work.
So we're going to put you on antibiotics for the next five years and as long as you've got
an antibiotic flowing through your veins, you know every time it peaks its little ugly
head outside the cell we're going to be able to kill it.
So there's some advantages to that and you may have seen people that have been cured using
long-term antibiotics.
Well you know there's lots of side effects to that, so that's not our preferred method.
There's other ways to kill it.
You can use nutraceuticals that are not TH1 stimulants.
So some of the examples of that would be MMS, Laura Cinnon, hydrogen peroxide, those are
just some examples, there's several more.
So those are the things that we test on a person and what is going to help kill that Lyme
disease.
Many times in our office none of those work for the patient either.
What always works to kill a Lyme disorder is using frequency medicine.
So that's what we use in our office.
So frequency medicine in the form of a rif machine.
There are a lot of people that call our office or see my videos or read my book and say we've
used a rif machine.
It didn't work.
We had somebody today call our office.
It happens at least three times a week.
Today call our office and they were eliminated because I was going to this doctor in California
and he's been doing the rif machine three times a week.
Going there for an hour a day he's taking so much money, it's cost to be a fortune and
it's just not help me.
Well I can tell you right now three times a week for an hour a day doing the rif machine
eight, going to do nothing even if you have the best rif machine, which I like the best
rif machine, the true rif, it's not going to work.
You need a lot more rif time than that, it just doesn't work and I say that by experience
because we used to do the rif in our office three times a week, one hour a day and we get
a little bit of result and the person would crash again.
So it just doesn't work and then we'd up it, we're going to do two hours, we're going
to do every day until we went to an at home program, it just didn't work.
So it's we went to an at home program, it always works.
We have not filled with a with a line patient, but we're doing a lot of the things too, but
that's frequency medicine is that they will talk about that at our next never's, never's
minute.